day four of the strikes here in
frankfurt and it's hitting lufthansa
where it hurts
half of the airline's lucrative
long-haul flights are grounded many are
losing patience with the strikers
it just doesn't seem responsible to me
to come into the negotiations with such
high demands
it's getting out of hand it's time they
started to think about how this affects
other companies too enough is enough
tens of thousands of passengers have
been affected since the strike was
called wednesday
it's the 12th round of walkouts since
the labor dispute erupted a year ago
pilots want higher wages and they're
fighting a plan to cut benefits
including generous payouts to those who
retire early
up until 2013 lufthansa allowed its
pilots to retire at 55.
then two years ago the carrier announced
it would end the plan
under intense financial pressure
the airline said it needed to cut costs
amid stiff competition from budget
airlines
since then lufthansa has handed over
most domestic flights to german wings
its own low-cost carrier
now it wants to do the same with its
long-haul flights and create a new
budget airline
with both sides digging in their heels
some worry the conflict could spill over
into the lucrative holiday season